[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking
[Music]
down no no we're breaking down
Invincible Invincible season 2 episode 3
baby it's now out and we have a lot to
talk about when it comes to aliens
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down all Easter eggs comic book
connections and things you might have
missed also I forgot to ask people for
thumbs up last week so this week I'm
going to need you to click the thumbs up
and then click it again to make up for
the twi is that right either way thanks
for clicking this let's get into the
brand new
[Music]
episode dad now we begin with Debbie
dropping Markov at University which is
where he moved to in the comics a lot of
this episode takes place during issue
zero which actually happens after issue
22 keep up yeah what it was right was
that Invincible had been running for
about 2 years and the readership was
slowly starting to pick up so what they
did is basically released this comic
that filled in a lot of the backstory of
what had happened it had Mark basically
talking to Amber and recapping all the
story of what had happened so far in the
end we had the pair kissing which then
took us directly into issue 23 just like
how they kind of could away for the sex
moments in this they then also use that
to transition into Allen the alien this
led us into getting the story we have
which takes up the majority of this
episode now you might remember last week
that principal Winslow said it was this
last year and people assumed that he was
retiring what's really going on though
is that he's now the dean of the
University though at the moment he
hasn't been reintroduced yet and this
entire scene's very heartbreaking for
Debbie as she's lost the family she's
been building for the last 20 years
Nolan left and we see that he's moved on
somewhere else and that marks now left
to go off and study away from home one
thing that I absolutely love about the
series though is how much it's fleshed
out what's going on with Debbie in the
comics she was often always just off in
the background whereas here they give
her way more character development all
this stuff last week with the house
that's completely new for the show as is
the support group that we see her going
to that kind of reminds me a lot of the
one from Avengers endgame in which cap
met with people that were affected by
the snap now the card for the group that
has a number on the back of it but the
front it also gave some Clues too this
was actually the morse code for SOS with
the group also being called that to now
as we learned this massively helped out
Olga and she was someone that lost her
superhero husband but due to the
circumstances Debbie isn't welcomed in
kind of Hing that she gets blamed for it
all even though she didn't really have
anything to do with it on the phone we
hear sorry no last names Debbie but Olga
told me about you which is later backed
up by first names only it's clearly
being set up like this in case there's
issues from heroes and villains loved
ones coming face to face I'm guessing
that even the super villains like Nolan
would have someone that they cared about
that might need support in a situation
like this now from here we cut to mark
readying his room and the first thing he
does is hang up a poster this is of his
childhood hero saian dog who in the
comics was called SE stock the poster
first showed up during issue two with it
being a change for the series to be a
doctor strange parody bring that over
from across his home we get someone
masquerading as him later in the episode
H's dog has the same outfit as strange
and his change it was done for a
specific reason discussing it last year
Robert Kirkman said it was down to the
property right so I'm guessing we've got
some legal Weagle wobbly stuff
interestingly science dog was also
created by Kirkman with him even getting
his own spin-off comic at one point now
about their Dawn we also have different
paries including Magnum PI but they've
got the pi symbol on the end of the logo
we also have lady Yaya instead of Lady
Gaga and it just helps to keep things
off in a slightly different Universe now
William's side is much cleaner and he
explains how they use a sock on the door
to Signal when the rooms occupied we
also see Marx brought across his toes uh
they're collectibles sorry sorry mate
and amongst these we can catch seon dog
and schag gorath parody Mark later ends
up chucking Sean's dog in the trash but
he has a change of heart cuz he's not
ready to let go yet kind of wish I'd
been told that when I was younger cuz I
threw away all my stuff as soon as I hit
14 spent the last 10 years trying to buy
them all back except this time they're
now five times the price yay so sad just
seeing the little lad in the bin and
yeah come here make come here I'll never
let go and the comics' story started off
in issue 25 which is when we open with
Mark down a comic book store the guy
behind the desk he kept making fun of s
dog and how crap the comic run was on
the hole Mark said he'd been buying them
forever though and in the end didn't
really want to break up his run it was
about him being unable to let go but
here I think it's way more impactful by
using the figure seon's dog was the
first character that was a hero to him
and in many ways this reflected his
father I don't think it's any
coincidence that Sean's dogs used a form
to connect with his dad and it's a
really clever way to bring this whole
thing together now after seeing a stck
on the door we then get to Amber's room
and I think that that X poster might be
a reference to Ed Sheeran the PA start
getting it on with se's dog falling to
the ground which maybe shows some man's
childhood's about to leave him behind at
this point Amber says wait you don't
have like super sperm or something do
you which might be a no to the Kevin
Smith talk about Superman brought up how
he'd really have to practice safety and
potentially wear a Kryptonite condom
when he was going in the lowest Lane ify
girls in for the tonight though she
knows what to do and we end up giving
the PE privacy we then get this voice
over and so dear audience perhaps it's
time to give Amber and Mark some privacy
which riffs on the comic in which we
transition Allen with the text block
saying and so dear readers we turn our
attentions elsewhere to give young Mock
grayon and Amber Bennett some privacy
from here we get what basically the
double page spread from issue 23 in
which we recount what happened with
yopin they were basically a peaceful
world that had achieved harmony with
nature but the vites ended up invading
the planet and destroying most of the
people there this is the tactic that the
vites used to use when they were
Superior in numbers as they couldn't be
outmatched by any forces in the Galaxy
however as they spread out and conquered
at the worlds their forces grew too thin
and thus they changed tactics eventually
what they do is what we saw with Nolan
where he went to a planet and pretended
to be its protector eventually they'd
weaken their forces and this would Usher
in the Vite Invasion now the show
slightly changes things up as they have
the unop rebelling by using their
weapons in the comics they just fled
into the stars and then started to
experiment on their young the ship
leaving the planet looks exactly the
same and they've pulled across these
elements brilliantly to tell alen's
backstory at this point they were
invited into the Coalition of planets
which was set up to tackle a Vite threat
he here we meet their leader theis for
the first time who's voiced by none
other than Peter Cullen the Vite
campaign has become the scourge of the
Galaxy if you recognize his voice it's
because he provided Optimus Primes and
thus is a major character that pops up
throughout the comics those who read it
know know he's got a little secret and I
can't wait to see how it's handled in
the show next to him we also see a
character that looks like battle beast
and they may end up tying his species
into the Coalition early on in the show
of the years xopin tried ways to
genetically improve their species to
fight the vites but many were born
disfigured that was until your boy Alan
the
[Music]
alien they saw a riff on the helmet
Wolverine had when he was Weapon X
without being a big red visor over the
front of the metal structure this was a
panel that appeared in the comics 2 with
the following shots also being similar
as well that included Allan fighting a
giant beast and also being laid out flat
on his back after he got beaten no
matter what happened Allan couldn't beat
the Vite and instead he was made as a
planetary evaluation officer as we
learned in season one he traveled out to
Earth and had even fought Nolan when
visiting our planet we see this moment
playing out and that happens in a
montage foreshadowing omn Man's big
return at the end now as you know this
was all one big mistake and he was meant
to go to urath but this helped him come
across mock Mark's obviously someone who
can help combat the Vite threat and now
we're getting breadcrumbs for the way
the story's going to go also love how
they changed the title card and this is
also what they did with Adam Eve which
was such a cool thing in her special now
his journey back to his headquarters is
built off the back of the comics but
they change up what happens with his
girlfriend General tella in the comics
she was more just a scany clad alien as
here she's a high ranking member of the
military if you think her uniform looks
familiar then that's cuz it's based off
the ones from Star Trek the Next
Generation there were a couple of panels
where Allan ended up saving a crew who
had designed to look like Bard and Cole
which Talia also a member of from here
we go out to the council with Allan
discussing Mark and how he went against
his father this whole scene is beat for
beat in the source material with it
being extremely important to the overall
Arc thus also mentions the Great Purge
which was the battle on vrum in which
only the strong survived this actually
wiped out half their population which in
the end led to their numbers being so
weak for years they've been searching
for someone like Mark who can help tear
open the vit's armor if you know what's
going on with Theus then you'll ALS be
aware of why his war against filtrum is
so important again I promised Amazon I
wouldn't be doing any future spoilers
but there's a very important thing that
happens with the character Talia says
also why are they breeding with other
races I thought vites believed in racial
Purity and again this is because their
numbers are so low they realize they'd
have to Boler them up by having kids
which is something that happened when
they infiltrate a planet vites of course
live for thousands and thousands of
years so having kids to carry on their
legacy is not always on their mind the
th they didn't have new thinkers come in
and question what they were doing and th
you didn't get you didn't get wokness
mate you didn't get wokness from the new
generation it was always bloody Ratt
boat W God there now theya suspects that
someone's a mole and we I'm joking by
the way now theya suspects that
someone's a mole and we see firstand
that this is the case someone's been
feeding the vit's info which leads to
the attack later on with Allan now at
this point he returns home which in the
comics is when we saw Talia Alan kind of
went back and forth on having sex with
her because his species was sworn to
only use breeding factories I don't know
if it's because they saw Talia pressing
into to it that they thought it might be
problematic so they just skip over it
and then cut away in the comics we cuted
the curtain which we saw up in the back
when he entered the room the wrer then
talked about returning to Mark which is
when we awkwardly cut back to settle on
the curtain from here we then went to a
satellite which is where Talia and Allan
went to in the source material Allen's
eating worms rise Talia has a crang type
creature that eats alen's food like how
it does in the comics at this point the
Vite attack which leads to them smashing
him like he's the like button they do
kind of change up the members of the
team but they keep the one guy that I
believe is looking the woman is totally
different in the book but she has
appeared in the series before when we
watch The Purge playing out you could
catch her amongst the soldiers and she's
very very mean looking with the blade at
the end of her hair this is actually a
character called Tula who appears much
later on in the comics but clearly
they've brought her in here to kind of
add a noticeable thing for readers to to
really kind of thorn over now they here
to interrogate Allan to find out what's
happened with Nolan as a Banning your
posters against theilr my way refusing
to answer they kick the crap out of him
in a scene that's just as brutal here as
it is in the comics they cut off his arm
smack out his eye and he gets put under
Medical Care Catalia crying in the
hospital at which point she's comforted
by thus now they change things up as we
see thus turning off his life support
which is a completely new thing purely
for the show in the comics he just said
this is the beginning of the end Raz
here he asks for forgiveness I have no
idea what they're doing with this and
it's nice to get a curve ball for the
way they're going to take things he
could suspect that it's Allen or he
might be even playing 40 chest to get to
the bottom of it as doing this might
bring out the mole either way let me
know your thoughts below and I actually
thought that might be the end of the
entry we even get credits than starting
up but at this point we then go back to
Earth Rex blod enters making things
awkward and at this point the pair have
an argument in the end she says she
relates with the immortal because he's
died as many times as she has really
helps to flesh his story out and it's
built off the back of a conversation
Immortal has in the comics there he
talked about how he'd finally met
someone who'd made him feel like it was
worth sticking around you have to see
with the immortal that he's watched
everyone he ever loves die so he has a
tough time sticking in one place
throughout his life he's lived as
several other people and at one point
was even Abraham Lincoln after he was
killed he came back and laid low but
decided to become a superhero when the
dawn of them first started out normally
at this point he would have left the
life behind but Kate's made him feel
like he should still stick around or re
blow just isn't able to understand and
Kate's looking for someone more mature
at this point shap Smith enters and just
weirds everyone out and he's kind of
like hello fellow humans I love all the
scenes where he's trying to fit in
though and as we know the man's of
course a martition now from here we cut
to Rudy in a scene that's very
reminiscent of Iron Man 3 in that we saw
a map of Killian's brain whereas here
he's trying to map his out here he wants
to determine why he's so afraid and
realizes that he's got something holding
him back man just wants to be with
monster girl and at this point he then
asks her out I'm getting the
word NS here looking young is also why
he chose to clone Rex and grow to 14 so
the pair could at least look like
they're the same age they are of course
old mentally uh but the comics did stuff
differently with Amanda saying she
didn't really like him cuz he looked
like a kid that happened during issue 36
with then Rudy asking her out after a
big battle now from here we could across
to the spouses of the superhero which is
where we see a talk being given by Theo
voiced by De digs he becomes a big
character in the episode that shows how
Humanity would react to Debbie if they
knew outside we see his Mark's not
really being replying and he's left the
nest and so she now just feels alone she
kind of finds a lot of commonality in
Theo and together the pair go to a b
this takes her mind off her son being
gone and we see she then deletes her
message elsewhere we see Rudy and Amanda
getting closer as they line up to go and
check out a movie the posters in the
back Riff on Dracula and the Wolf Man
and they ask for tickets to midnight
Slaughter in the comics it was called
machine gun Slaughter with a scene
playing off the opening of issue 37
ironically the guy that offered them
tickets to see s dog uh and I was
thinking they might go with San dog
however the guys in the episode of lot
so can understand why they were like
maybe let's not have him as every single
reference now how they got around it
there is that Rudy noticed someone
wearing a Knicks jacket and he told the
guy that this was his dad he then went
over and said something about how the
Knicks are the best team but the guy
selling the tickets he's disagreeing
with that that fact let's say so the
dude Shadow back that he was telling the
truth and thus Rudy and Amanda were able
to go in also I don't know anything
about the Knicks disclaimer guys no
don't know anything about them so if
they're not the best yet make sure you
drop it in the comments fill those
comments up with lots of interactions
and engagement now the show Manda show
she's used to this kind of thing and
gets an adult to say that she's their
parent from here they then head out to
bamore and I was kind of hoping that
we'd see Eve here alas we don't but Rudy
gets to experience new things as man's
really never had a life outside his tank
out of the bar Theo drops a name Alana
who we met in episode one of season 1
didn't didn't exactly stick around and
she was not known as the green ghost she
was a photographer who after ingesting
an amulet became a character based on
the Green Lantern in the comics they
were originally a man but I like the
change up here so they can go down this
route Theo and Debbie are very much
opposites in every way with the former
not having to deal with the secrets that
the ladder did across at the University
we also see Mark dealing with his own
issues too as William brings up how much
he misses Rick this was a character that
was changed into a reiman during the da
Sinclair a that Cecil is since being
trying to fix at this point we get a
knock at the door which is when we then
see seon Stog yeah it's a slight change
up from the comics as it happened in
that while Mark was still at home it was
Debbie who ended up opening up the door
and at this point it then led into a
fight makes sense that Mark takes it
away from his classmates here Raz
originally decided to just start
fighting him they fly because in the
comics e explains to mark that humans
never actually tend to look up at one
point they change into their costumes at
school and none of the humans see them
because they they are smaller and more
insignificant sorry guys now Amber is
someone who actually does look up though
which makes Mark believe that she's
special and will understand his life now
both the comic and show Mark questions
the dog why he's like this and the
facade clearly doesn't hold up both have
the reveal Ed it's an insect with the
comic being something that has him using
a costume he says the journey to your
world has taken me most of my life and
in the source material we learn how
short this is most of the bugs they only
live for 9 months which explains how omn
man became their leader they don't even
live long enough to remember a time when
he wasn't and thus he's managed to rise
up in society desperate to reconnect
with Mark he sent out this Messenger to
help bring him to him William kind of
peer pressures him into it and we get a
scene in which he informs Cil that he's
leaving in the show they really play up
the tension and I feel like him further
turning his back on Cecil's orders going
to drive a wedge between them I get the
feeling the show is going to have Cil
trying to take down mark because he
believes that he could end up becoming
his father he also ends up reaching out
to Amba which is a bit impersonal cuz he
calls her from the ship in the comic you
went to her room whereas here he just
calls her but he tells her that he loves
her I love
you guessing that the connection dropped
and hey young Love's tough now from here
we get a six day journey across space in
which Mark slumps about in the chair
this perfectly mimics what's in the
comic with us lulling us into a false
sense of security that's why it felt so
impactful with what we got in the end
with the reveal of Nolan coming straight
out the blue the though they use that to
culminate the Debbie story in which he
admits to Theo that her husband was omn
man even though she's breaking down Theo
doesn't show any sympathy and warns her
that the group might turn against her
it's such a brutal way to take things
and I was genuinely thinking he might
say it's not her fault but nope man's
colder than omn calling her a pet I do
love your mother but she's more like a a
pet to me at this point she looks up to
the stars and this is where omn man of
course headed into it's also where Mark
now gone to and we see as he's reunited
with his father just like the comics
he's taken through the planet before
coming face to face with his dad holding
out his hand he then says the exact same
lines that he does in the comics hello
son it's been a while this brings the
entry to a close for real now and as
many of you know I got to talk to co sha
executive producer and writer Simon
riopa about this character change the
the main reason I fell in love with
Invincible in the first place is the
arcs that the characters go on and it
starts off is quite a simple story of
like a a hero origin story and then it
just the break neck twists in it pun
intended are absolutely insane but then
you sort of start to feel like side with
the villains as well which obviously
includes omn man and you have an episode
where obviously Mark goes to to meet his
father again when you're creating these
characters do you feel sympathetic for
them or in the back of your mind are you
thinking oh this guy's terrible but he's
great to write
for well so I mean you know I'm sure
you've heard this term Rec but like
nobody thinks they're the bad guy yeah
you know uh characters don't I mean
there are some exceptions but for the
most part omn man thinks he's doing his
duty to his people like he's a sleeper
agent we've had sleeper agents in in
real world history right that's happened
you know people have done terrible
things in the cause of like you know for
their Nation you know throughout history
and throughout Wars so omn man doesn't
think he's a monster he starts to
question whether he is uh I think going
forwards but when he's doing the actions
like initially he thinks this is what he
has to do this is his duty so we try to
treat things realistically that way you
know are there psychopaths are there
crazy people yes obviously but you know
for most of our characters they're doing
what they think is right or what they
have have to do so that's where we we
start anyway with most of our most of
our villains you know even angstrom Levy
like he has an idea of what he's trying
to do and he has a reason for doing it
he's not just an insane person being
insane yeah I love that answer in the
end that closes out the entry and it was
another real kind of analysis of the
wake of Nolan's destruction talked about
before how I think this is very much
like a superhero version of a parent
divorce in which you go and see your
dad's off do doing his own thing seeing
what Debbie went through reminded me a
lot of my own parents one it was just
taken to the extreme with it being about
omn man still now there's a lot of
complexities here with Mark's love for
his childhood toys even being used to
manipulate him omn man would of course
know about his son's love for it and
yeah just using that as a way to bring
him to the planet who cold cold hearted
guy he knows that he probably wouldn't
have come any other way and this whole
way to get him back it's just one big
manipulation scheme it's kind of like
when your parents get divorced in to try
and bribe you with toys and I I just was
blown away at the extra layers to it it
adds a wealth of subtext to what's going
on and in the end this was a really
character-driven episode that took
things in so many interesting directions
I also love the Allen the alien insert
which on First Watch just came out of
nowhere still though it was integrated
into the episode so well and I hope
you've enjoyed our Trek through the show
obviously please leave all your comments
below and huge thank you for checking
out the video that thumbs up as always
Mass ly appreciated and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please click the
join button get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up all kinds of
tops like our Theory time one house of
dragon stuff Marvel teas and a lot more
we drop new designs on there all the
time too so definitely keep an eye out
for them and thank you if you bought one
now if you want something else to watch
we've got another video on screen right
now so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
checking out the video I've been your
host Paul and I hope to see you next
week take care peace